[Music]
the family has always been a central
building block of society but families
have changed dramatically in the rich
world over the past 50 years he knows he
has a donor he knows that we're both his
parents he knows he doesn't have a dad
and all of that and it's just normal
changes to society mean that the old
model of a bread winning husband in a
stay-at-home wife has all but collapsed
a single mom support my own children
is the normal nowadays and the different
ways rich and poor families raise their
children are increasing social
inequality we are basically paying for
preschool what I paid for college
[Music]
fifty years ago families didn't look
like this we're so gay we work together
live together and love it
today gay families like Maggie and Joe
ELLs are widely accepted in the rich
world there are so many gay families in
San Francisco it's amazing it is
becoming increasingly normalized but
within this photo a generation ago
it was almost unthinkable that same-sex
couples would get married look at this
one this one's really pretty I like this
one but now most people in rich
countries think gay marriage is fine I
really really wanted our families to
accept our marriage as a marriage and
not just like a girlfriend and I think
until that time I swear I think my
family just thought I was in a phase for
you know 15 years you were right the
wedding definitely had that effect on
our families they they're in it with us
now
fears that gay marriages would undermine
heterosexual ones have proven unfounded
and this is one reason why marriage
equality has spread so extraordinarily
fast before 2001 gay marriage was not
legal anywhere in the world since then
it's been legalized in nearly all rich
countries and developing nations are
starting to follow suit in California
the the right to get married was on and
off but I think who months before our
wedding was when it became permitted so
that was a big part of our ceremony it's
a far cry from the 1960s when families
typically consisted of a dad who went to
work a stay-at-home mum and three or
more kids better access for women to
contraception education and jobs has
changed this traditional family portrait
[Music]
across the globe family is a shrinking
nowhere more so than in South Korea
[Music]
here a growing number of women are
rejecting marriage and having children
all together like goalie who is 26
oh yeah all know them well Gary upon me
there to Medina like many South Korean
women go and have friends are well
educated she says traditional employers
make it hard to combine a career with
marriage and motherhood took her on a
hot young kid or cushy one unit and
entail Koryo dog into another put on yon
take our kingdoms hired a scorecard on
top and I don't wanna go I don't wanna
back off a choreo a look at when to the
Hashi that bar let's move on to cuddly
we do here is your cool it's a cool
yogurt honey don't dis your king dad
cook it has a Russian and also we took
our food August us all go works in IT
but is also a vlogger on YouTube where
she urges South Korean women to be more
assertive Yogi's were all bleating but
soon Hong da da da da a powerful ta how
you got Windham your song little dirty
joke you car toy reporter a Bonnie's
heroin hockey table name
[Music]
she believes South Korean men are part
of the problem many expect their wives
to do all the housework and childcare
even if they have a job they call each
other about the policy Tony Hall you're
taller
she's only because I'm cool
[Music]
cuts on his own then I don't have all a
[ __ ] on house making humming game this
is talking in a large amount got more I
don't cut only rich kingdom crow woman's
and then cut me about being I didn't
have you I needed them
there is a huge mismatch of expectations
around marriage in South Korea
most men want a 1950s style relationship
whereas women want something more modern
and equal
the result is they often end up not
marrying or having kids at all
and that's left South Korea with a
problem its population is in freefall in
1960 the average South Korean woman had
six children in 2018 that picker shrank
to less than one a fertility rate of one
means each generation is half as big as
the previous one and in South Korea this
means there are fewer workers to support
the country's aging population in rural
areas
men are viewed as poor prospects by
South Korean women so the government is
helping these men to find Brides from
poorer countries state-funded
assimilation centers like this teach
immigrant brides how to cook Korean food
how to speak Korean and even how to deal
with Korean mothers and me like most of
her classmates studying here today 19
year old went econ a toy is from Vietnam
she recently married a South Korean man
40-year old Kim Dae hyung who found her
through a matchmaking website the one
can your wife was not any trouble
troyzan sure as I wipe around half of me
touching will be how important
disposable over a fifth of married South
Korean farmers and fishermen have tied
the knot with a foreigner angle while
enjoy watching the curandera always
but cross-cultural unions can be
difficult and around 1/5 of marriages
between South Korean men and foreign
women end in divorce within four years
this video of a man beating his foreign
wife caused widespread outrage 50 years
ago in most rich countries domestic
violence was considered normal now it is
universally condemned and rates have
fallen sharply by three quarters in
America alone since the mid-1990s
today other factors are more likely to
affect the stability of families and
these are contributing to a growing gulf
between middle-class and working-class
families in most rich countries if you
don't go to university you're more
likely to have kids outside of marriage
and women who don't finish high school
are more likely to end up as single
mothers than women who have a degree
[Music]
[Music]
I'm a single mom because at 20 weeks
pregnant dad decided that he didn't want
to be around dong-won so I let him walk
it was easier to wallet and walk then
than it was for him to actually build an
attachment with the kids and then walk
in Jamie's hometown of Hartlepool in
northeast England 70% of babies are born
outside marriage hey Shawny we're gonna
cook these tonight like her twins Shawn
and Liam
I am the solar owner of the household
without my income
and my kids interrupt me Oh get in fetch
me cucumbers because they awesome can be
a financial struggle to accomplish movie
in Hartlepool in the 1960s men did heavy
working shipyards and factories which
was much better paid than any job their
wives could find so the women stayed at
home with the kids but as technology
advances manual workers dried up and
uneducated men have struggled to find
good jobs
[Applause]
everything's industrial here in
Hartlepool is gone there's nothing left
what comes with industrial decline
poverty depression anxiety family
breakups marriages separating suicide
has all sorts at common because people
feel the can provide for their family if
the only men available like steady jobs
and don't help around the home some
women feel they are better off alone it
can't be hard to be a man I presume it
would be hard you know having to step
back a little bit and realize that you
might not be the breadwinner and that
you are actually you haven't to rely on
a woman to feed the family and keep the
roof over the head so yeah it can't be
hard for a month middle-class families
have remained solid in rich countries
over the past 50 years while
working-class families hope grow much
less stable women with the university
degree are more likely than women who do
not finish high school to be married and
raise children with their husband as a
team and this is contributing to a
growing social divide a divide that's
increasingly apparent in the very
different ways middle and working class
families are raising their children
although American fathers from all
backgrounds do much more child care than
the previous generation today wealthier
fathers spend much more time with their
kids than their poorer counterparts do
[Music]
most of the weakness for example my wife
takes care of them
taking them to school thinking of the
mob and then when I come from work I fit
them I play with him a better pair take
that and get in a bath and go to sleep
and during the weekends we switch a
little bit my husband always comes back
home and takes care of that like dinner
sometimes or breakfast during the
weekend so it's a very like 5050 I would
say harvard-educated Gerardo shares the
childcare duties with his wife Perla who
also studied there
the couple are investing time and money
and stimulating their children
intellectually we do think her too for
example like abacus classes after school
or she's like starting to learn how to
do additions and subtractions and
sometimes we come home and do a little
bit of extra work by the age of three
the children of professional families
have heard 30 million more words than
children from poorer backgrounds from
zero to five it's very important that
you spend time with your kids from there
it's like you feel they already have the
values ingrained and the Securities
positive what I think
a child's early years are the most
important for cognitive development so
children of professionals have a head
start long before they start school the
pushy middle class style of raising kids
is sometimes called intensive parenting
[Music]
so intensive parenting as it's the idea
that parents are investing an enormous
amount of time and energy in their
children's development early on Sean
Riordan is a professor of poverty and
equality in education at Stanford
University and has studied the influence
of class on parenting and how well kids
do in school it's it's as if you thought
of your child as an orchid a delicate
flower that needs daily attention as
opposed to thinking of your child in the
way that parents used to think of their
children as a tree or a bush we don't
water the trees or the bushes they it's
in their nature to grow and barring any
sort of catastrophe they'll do just fine
middle-class parents not only talk more
to their children and take them to
ballet chess and extra math classes they
also compete to get them into the best
schools actually where school is less
than a mile from here and he said by you
also they have teacher school time
Mandarin and full time English and all
of them have master's degrees and very
high level education
[Music]
Gerardo and Perlas daughter Elizabeth is
learning five languages including
Mandarin I think going to the school
she's gonna be more open to learning and
talking with people like turning around
and speaking Mandarin and tooken around
and speaking Spanish okay but all this
education doesn't come cheap
Elizabeth's preschool costs thirty one
thousand dollars a year
definitely costs of take care and
preschool have been way more than we
expected originally we were basically
paying for preschool what I paid for
college
[Music]
so in the richest communities in United
States the average student scores three
to four grade levels above the national
average and in the poorest communities
with average student scores maybe two to
three grade levels below the national
average so the difference in performance
is a result of differences in
opportunities
[Music]
a gulf is growing between wealthy
families that stick together and raise
high achieving kids and blue-collar
families that struggle to do either this
gap is about much more than money
well-educated men are more likely than
in the past to marry highly educated
women the children of these clever
parents are more likely to be clever and
the children of stable families are more
likely to raise stable and high
achieving families of their own as you
get a society that's more divided
economically and educationally
increasingly run the risk of having a
society that doesn't have empathy for
other parts of itself the risk is you
end up with a kind of more socially and
economically polarized society as a
result of this well educated families
have become success factories passing on
their advantages to their kids
by contrast many poorer children grow up
with no first-hand experience of what a
stable family looks like
[Music]
as men and women have grown more equal
over the past 50 years families have
grown much less so
you